معنا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا بك حضره
اللواء نبدا من السؤال الذي انهينا به هذا
العرض هل تغيرت اهداف الحرب التي اندلعت
في الرابعه والعشرين من فبراير الماضي
نعم تغيرت ليس بسبب الشتاء ولكن سبب تعثر
العمليات العسكريه الروسيه التوجيه
السياسي كان واضحا السيطره على اوكرانيا
عزل القياده الى غير ذلك وظهرت تسريبات
واضحه تحدثت على ان العمليه بنيت على اساس
10 ايام في حدها الاقصى يكون قد تمت
السيطره على اوكرانيا فشل الجزء الاول او
الصفحه الاولى من الحرب في معركه العاصمه
والانسحاب ثم بدا القتال في الجبهه
الشرقيه وفشلت في الجزء الشمالي الشرقي
وبالتالي حصر القتال في الاقاليم الاربعه
تقريبا اللي هو لوجان
وخسرت القوات الروسيه اجزاء في تركيا
اذا نعم تغيرت الاهداف بحكم الواقع
الميداني بسبب عوامل عديده سواء صمود جيش
او الدعم الغربي الى غير ذلك
ناتي الان الفتره الحاليه هي فتره الشتاء
الشتاء بدا يلقي بظلاله على العمليات
العسكريه لماذا لان القدره القتاليه
للمقاتل وقدرته على استخدام المعدات تنخفض
بصوره كبيره جدا بسبب اولا ظروف الطقس
درجات الحراره
وطبيعه الارض اذا الان اتوقع تغييرا
جوهريا في خطوط العمليات العسكريه الرئيس
الروسي كان واضحا بان عمد المعركه طويل
وهناك اتهام لامريكا ان المعارك همم
امريكا
صممتها على اساس تنتهي مبدئيا في نهايه
2000 2025 اذا دعني اقول فتره لا اقول
بيات شتوي ولكن هناك تحديدات واضحه جدا
على مجريات المعارك باستثناء نقطه هنا
ونقطه هناك في اطرافه الايمان في اطراف
باخموت الى غير ذلك ما عدا ذلك فقط هو
تبادل للقسم المدفعي والصاروخي واستخدام
الطائرات والمسيرات لكن هل يمكن القول ان
الطرفين بلغ الحد الاقصى لاستعمال القوه
المتاحه لديهما
يعني نعم في الجانب الروسي مجرد الاعلان
التعبئه الجزئيه همم الحصول على طائرات
شاهد من ايران الحديث عن التزوج بصواريخ
همم عفوا ذخائر مدفعيه من كوريا الشماليه
استخدام صواريخ اس 300 في دور همم الهجوم
الارضي هذا يدل على انها لا اقول استنزفت
كامبل بالقوه العسكريه ولكنها بلغت الحد
الاقصى في الاستخدام القوه المتاحه
باستخدام باستثناء الخيار النووي يضاف الى
ذلك اوكرانيا من اليوم الاول تقريبا زوجه
بكافه قدراتها ولولا الجسر الجو الغربي لم
يستطعت ان تقاتل 10 اشهر
المسيرات الامن حضره اللواء تلعب دور
رئيسي هل تتوقع ان يستمر لها ان تستمر لها
كل هذه حتى خلال فصل الشتاء
نعم تحديدات الطقس عليها محدوده جدا اثنين
هي تكلفه جديده اذا تحدثنا عن 20,000
دولار للطائره يمكن الان استخدامها باعداد
كبيره جدا من كلا طرفيع لكن الاعلام
الفارقه ما جرى قبل ثلاثه ايام ان يتم
ارسال طائرات قيل انها
سوفيتيه الصنع تم تحديثها وتطويرها في
داخل الاوكراني مداها يصل الى 1000 كم
وزنها 75 كيلو متر هاجمت ثلاثه قواعد منها
قاعدتين كما اشرت على مسافه 480 الى 500
كلم وعدت الى الحق اضرار في القاذفات
الاستراتيجيه همم 165 و 95 نعم ستلعب دورا
كبيرا لانها تقتصد في الجود وفي التكاليف
وتوفر او تصفر الخسائر البشريه في
الطيارين
شكرا جزيلا لك اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري واستراتيجي من عمان